شعر بشيء بارد تحت قميصه وظن ان زجاجه
المياه قد انسكبت عليه لكنه تفاجا بمشهد
مرعب عندما استدار الى الخلف ليجد افعى
كبرى تحت مقعده هذه الحادثه المخيفه وقعت
مع طيار في الجو عندما كان يقود طائره
خاصه على متنها اربعه ركاب في اجواء جنوب
افريقيا هذه اللحظه المرعبه تعامل معها
الطيار رادولف بشجاعه ابلغ الركاب ومراقب
الحركه الجويه انه يواجه حاله طارئه نوعا
ما ثم اضطر للطيران لمده 15 دقيقه
والثعبان ملتف على قدميه قبل ان يهبط
بامان وبعد هبوط الطائره تم استدعاء صائد
الثعابين للبحث عن الزائر السام لكن حسب
الطيار فان الافعى قد اختفت تماما حينها
وامضه هو وبعض المهندسين اليومين التاليين
في تفكيك الطائره بحثا عنها دون ان يجدوها